so let's continue with our conversation
around factors of production for a firm
and we're going to focus on the labor
market and so we've already drawn axes
like this multiple times where a
horizontal axis this is the quantity
quantity of labor that's being employed
by a firm and then the vertical axis
this is our wage rate and so this is
we're looking at the economics for firm
and we're looking at how much labor is
it rational for this firm to employ and
we've talked about the marginal revenue
product multiple times this is a view of
how much incremental revenue can the
firm get every time it brings on one
more labor unit and we've talked about
that we typically see it like a downward
sloping line like this because you have
diminishing returns every time you add
one more labor unit the marginal revenue
product of that labor it goes a little
bit down and so and that's when you have
diminishing returns so there's marginal
revenue products and I'll be very
particular this time this is of Labor we
could do a similar marginal revenue
product of other factors like land or
capital now to change things up in this
video we're not just going to talk about
a firm that operates in a perfectly
competitive labor market if we did then
its marginal factor cost would be
whatever the market wage rate would be
it would be a horizontal line like this
so you would have a marginal factor cost
of labour but we're not going to talk
about a firm that's in a perfectly
competitive labor market we're going to
talk about a firm that is a monopsony
employer a very fancy word so it is a
monopsony not a monopoly a monopoly now
what is a monopsony mean well you could
almost view it as the reverse of what a
monopoly is a monopoly is you have one
seller so one seller and many buyers so
many many buyers so that is a monopoly
monopoly right over there
a monopsony is when you have
one buyer so one buyer and many sellers
and so you have many many sellers so
this right over here is a monopsony firm
monopsony and in the context that we're
talking about working about labor
markets so this one instead of saying
one buyer you could say this is one
buyer of labor so you could say one
employer one employer and the sellers of
laborers well a seller of labor well
these are many potential potential
workers potential workers and there are
many real-world examples that approach
monopsony employers let's say we're in a
small town and there's only one hospital
so they're going to be the monopsony
employers of healthcare workers of say
nurses and so it's interesting about a
monopsony employer is they're not just
going to take whatever the wage rate is
they have to essentially they have a
supply curve for labor in that market
and so for example in this market when
wages when wages are low there's going
to be a low supply of labor a lot nob
not many people are going to want to
walk work for that hospital and then as
wages go up more and more and more
people are going to want to work for
that monopsony employer and so this is
our labor labor supply supply curve now
I'm going to ask you a question I'm
going to tell you right now it is a
trick question what is going to be the
rational quantity for this firm to hire
now you might be tempted to say well
it's just the same thing we could we
would just want to keep hiring as long
as our marginal revenue product of labor
is higher than the cost of labor and
that would be true if you could afford
to pay everyone a different rate if this
first unit of labor you can pay this
someone this much and then everyone that
you hire you have to just pay them a
little bit more but that's not the way
that it typically works in the real
world you often think about having to
whatever the wage is if we decide that
this is
the quantity of labor that we want to
bring on you wouldn't pay this wage just
to that incremental person you would
have to pay that wage to everyone and so
to think about what is the rational
quantity of labor to bring on for this
firm we wouldn't need to think we need
to calculate or at least visualize what
the marginal factor cost of labor here
which is going to be different than our
labor supply curve and to help us
visualize that let me set up a little
table here so I'm just going to make up
some numbers so look we're going to
think about the quantity of labor so
let's just go 0 1 2 3 4 and then let's
think about the price of labor and so
let's say when the quantity of labor is
1 the price of labor is 3 and then it
goes up as we break as we if we want to
hire more people well the price of labor
goes up to 4 it goes up to 5 goes up to
6 keeps going and then what would be the
total cost of labor so total labor cost
well you could figure that out if you
hire one unit at three dollars per unit
one times three is three two units at
four dollars per unit remember you're
going to have to pay everyone the same
amount so it's not like you can just pay
this first person three dollars and only
the second person four dollars in which
case this would be seven but if you're
going to hire two you don't have to pay
everyone four dollars so your total cost
is 8 here 2 times 4 3 times 5 your total
cost is 15 your total cost here is 24
and so now we could think about what is
our marginal factor cost of labor so
when you bring on that incremental unit
of labor
how much incremental cost are you taking
on well when you go from 1 to 2 units
your total cost goes from 3 to 8 so your
marginal factor cost has is 5 this is
plus 5 right over here when you go from
2 to 3 your marginal factor cost you
went from 8 to 15 so 8 to 15 you went up
by 7 and once again this is because when
you want to hire more people you're
going to have to pay more to track those
incremental people but they have to pay
that higher 8
to everyone and so you see that the
marginal factor cost of labour is going
up twice as fast as our supply bird
supply curve our labor supply curve
every incremental unit we're adding one
here every incremental unit we're adding
to and we could see it again to go from
15 to 24 you have to add nine so our
marginal factor cost of labor is nine
and so looking at this is an example you
see that your marginal factor cost of
labour is going to go up at twice the
slope of your labor supply curve so your
marginal factor cost of labour is going
to look something like this it's going
to go up twice as fast marginal factor
cost of labour and now this might be
ringing a bell this might seem like what
we studied in the past when we looked at
a monopoly or an imperfect competitor
firm and we talked about the demand for
its goods and we also talked about its
marginal revenue and the marginal
revenue curve went had twice the
negative slope as the demand curve and
here we see everything just flipped over
because we're not net we're now not
talking about revenue for the firm and
marginal revenue for the firm we are
talking about costs for the firm these
are inputs for the firm but now what
would be the rational wage rate and
what's the rational quantity of labor
for this firm well now that we've done
the marginal analysis we would see that
it's rational for the firm to keep
bringing on more and more people as long
as the marginal revenue product of labor
for each incremental unit is higher than
the marginal factor cost of labour for
each incremental unit and so it would
keep hiring until you get to this point
right over here so it would be rational
for it to bring on this quantity of
labor and what would be the wage that it
would pay well you might be tempted to
just go right over here and say it would
pay this wage but remember it doesn't
have to pay this wage at this quantity
of labor the labor supply curve tells us
that the market wage would be right over
here so it would be paying
it would be paying this wage it would be
paying
this wage right over here so this is
something for you to maybe ponder on a
little bit more but the big picture is
is when we're dealing with a monopsony
firm so it is the only person hiring in
the market or something that's
approaching approaching a monopsony firm
it's going to have its own labor supply
curve and the way you think about what a
rational quantity for it to hire is you
would think about the marginal factor
cost of labour which is going to go up
at twice the slope and where that
intersects the marginal revenue product
well that tells you the quantity and
then the labor supply curve will tell
you the wage for that quantity